with tomorrow night's Oscars approaching
it's a time to celebrate the movies but
movie theaters are still having their
struggles according to a report this
week by the National Association of
theater owners the U.S has lost over 2
000 movie screens since the start of the
pandemic there is an effort underway to
save endangered screens especially in
small town America one theater at a time
and it's being spearheaded by some
familiar names Nancy Chen has the story
thank you
one film The Majestic captured both the
magical Allure of the movie theater and
the uniquely communal experience of
seeing a film on the big screen this
television thing why would you want to
stay home and watch a little box I mean
how can you call that entertainment
alone in your living room
where's the other people
where's the audience
where's the magic Cinemas especially
those in small towns have long been part
of the history in the local communities
they serve but their future is now in
question already hard hit by the rise of
streaming theaters across the country
were forced to close during the pandemic
many never opened their doors again
there is nothing like the cinema
experience
there's not I deeply believe in the
power of movies we've got to investigate
gather evidence and provide proof actor
Patrick Wilson who's
who says Cinema has helped shape who we
are we all have those moments in our
life of going I remember seeing Star
Wars I remember seeing Zorro in the 70s
where you are in your life is very often
defined by movies I don't think that's
going away not if Wilson has anything to
say about it the performer is stepping
into a far different role from being in
the movies to renovating the theaters
that play them when the cinema in
Wilson's hometown of Montclair New
Jersey shut down he and his neighbor
came up with the idea to save the
nation's Small Town Theaters we are
thrilled to be back once again sharing
movies the way they are intended to be
seen their Endeavor is called Cinema lab
I am the chief experience officer I'm in
charge of your experience here that big
title it is no it is do you put that on
your resume no not yet but it will I
don't know if this is going to help me
get acting jobs but Cinema lab takes
over theaters that have closed or are
about to and renovates them with
state-of-the-art technology and
comfortable seating can I get a large
lemonade please a large miniature yeah
they also add upgraded meals alcoholic
beverages and special programming geared
toward the community is this what it
takes to survive these days as a theater
I think so you've got to curate an
audience that wants to go back to the
theater because there are certain
demographics that aren't going back very
much since starting two years ago the
company has opened 2
research with
more in the works their first in South
Orange New Jersey just down the road
from Wilson's Hometown this is it this
is it Welcome to The Village at sopac
and this is the first Cinema lab theater
this is this is our our Flagship as they
say and as Chief experience officer
Wilson has been involved in every detail
here from the special events they host
with actors like Tom Holland hi everyone
to the concessions themselves there's
nothing like coming in and smelling the
smell of popcorn we have we've got
fantastic popcorn what was important for
me is to find that balance between look
you're coming to a movie you want to
indulge so I had a hard pitch for the
icy machine and even some of my
partner's like what nobody buys Icees
it's literally our biggest seller but
even with change there is still an nod
to tradition particularly at one of
their current projects in New Canaan
Connecticut original sign so we're
trying to keep as many original pieces
as we can that's where we met Wilson's
business partner another rather familiar
name Luke Parker Bowles who also happens
to be the nephew of Queen consort
Camilla he's also Wilson's neighbor and
was equally distraught when their
theater shut down all the kids used to
hang out at the Bellevue in monka and
now my daughter hangs out at the CVS
parking lot
and I thought that if that's a
reflection of America today that we've
lost this Center
in so many towns there's something we
had to do about it it was very very
clear
[Music]
a film producer whose credits include
the Beloved holiday rom-com Love
Actually Parker Bowles the company's CEO
says his experiences back home have
shaped his vision my partners I want
it to be more like a pub experience if
you can think it's an English pub you
can get it go and get a drink you can do
Sunday Times crossword or you're going
to see a movie it doesn't matter it's a
community center it's a community center
but with an elegance and a comfort level
that makes it more than that that's the
idea behind the New Canaan Playhouse
which opened in 1923 after closing
during the pandemic the playhouse is set
to reopen later this year for its 100th
anniversary remodeled by Cinema lab and
so this is and you have to use your
imagination Nancy that's a little this
is going to be our event space and our
our members Club my favorite bit is this
beautiful bar that you can imagine
right here
that you can look out from
onto the 50-yard line of New Canaan that
is the center of town and now the
company wants the cinema lab Community
to grow with five theaters open by the
end of the year and 15 by 2026 as more
towns across the country reach out
what's been the most rewarding part
about all of this for you just seeing
busyness in the lobby just seeing people
sit there people hang out people smiling
a desire to want to keep the art form
vibrant we're just starting but if I can
shape people's experience
then I've I've succeeded let's go
getting the curtain to rise again for a
True Hollywood ending for CBS Saturday
morning I'm Mitzi Chen in South Orange
New Jersey
and I can attest to the impact of that
theater when it's shut down it just
literally killed so much enthusiasm was
this it was the focal point for so many
young people and now it's back because
it's where they came together yes I mean
it's we all remember those movies where
you went to as a family like movie in
Star Wars
right not even just a family with your
friends
going and that was what you did those
great stuff